so men in 2023 especially white men are
discriminated against for jobs diversity
quotas have led to men being
discriminated against and passed over
for high-paying jobs and given to women
one industry I have seen this in is the
tech field I remember being about 22
years old and I was working in copier
sales and I had a woman tell me that she
worked in Tech and that I should get a
tech job because it made about six
figures I made about $45,000 a year at
my sales job and I thought wow what
would I have to do to double my salary
that sounds amazing now this chick told
me about her day-to-day job and really
it seemed easier than what I was doing
and I worked in an all mail space The
Coop copier sales um which is what I
sold is not typically what you want to
do with your free time I'll tell you
that there were not many women that
wanted to sign up for this job it is a
very competitive industry IND and really
boring to be honest I also worked there
during coid so the entire industry was
on the
decline now I thought to myself wow that
sounds amazing
Tech um I can't even remember what she
did in a day honestly this was so long
ago I just remember thinking that wow
that doesn't seem that hard during it
was interesting because during Co about
a year later this woman got laid off and
I saw thousands of people in the tech
industry get laid off in the next couple
of years um and it it was interesting
because if you looked at Twitter and you
saw before and after photo of of the
Twitter team um when they cut off like
80% of its staff really it was mostly
men that made the cut there were a
couple women that stayed in the company
but it was the exception not the rule I
am always willing to acknowledge and big
up exceptional women but what I am tired
of is them giving stupid women jobs that
they don't deserve now there was a woman
woman in Tech career conference now
again I personally and I don't know the
industry that well so I could be wrong
my guess is there are a lot of useless
jobs in tech for women my reasoning
behind this is really that I keep seeing
all the women get laid off when the
rubber meets the road and they have to
make Cuts now the interesting thing
about feminism and Men is that men will
always find a way around things if you
make the game rigged men will somehow
figure out how to play it now feminists
and oftentimes in these woke tech
companies where these women really
haven't experienced reality because
they're overpaid um you have a lot of
lefist chicks and liberal chicks that
work at these companies the woman I'm
thinking of that I spoke to a couple of
years ago was absolutely a woke
leftist and um so the men decided that
they were going to identify as
nonbinary and apply for these jobs at
this conference let's pull it up career
conference for females in Tech was taken
over by m attendees they were there just
purely for the career fair social media
Clips filmed at the Grace Hopper the
world's largest gathering of women
technologists show men standing in line
to meet with recruiters this is a space
for women in Tech this is one of those
few limited resources that isn't for you
it's for us some of the meal attendees
reportedly lied about being non-binary
just to get in but it's interesting that
the large majority of the people that
actually ended up in the event had name
tags with he him and have no searchable
history of identifying as non-binary
several Tech workers defended the men
for trying to capitalize on job
opportunities not meant for them seeing
that the entire concept was wrong let's
be honest there is no need for a
conference just for women because if it
was the opposite of for men then it
would be sexist just because you are a
woman doesn't give you the right to talk
to a big firm recruiter guys work just
as hard and they don't get that chance I
think this is the funniest thing I've
seen all day yes okay women based women
out there the two women that watch my
show can we please stop can we please
start protesting these freaking women in
business women empowerment we don't need
this if you are a talented woman in
business you will succeed we don't need
these stupid quotas we don't need these
stupid conferences these stupid handouts
all it does is bring stupid women
together to feel like they're more
important than they are if you deserve
the job you would not need this I
am so TI sorry I am so tired I am so
tired because do you know what it does
the women that actually deserve these
jobs and actually put in the work are
discredited because they give out so
many high-paying jobs to stupid women
idiotic women leftist chicks and
honestly I think it's amazing that these
guys are protesting this um why do why
do women get special privileges to meet
with these recruiters if the resume was
good they would have experience to show
and they would get the jobs and it's
interesting because even the recruiters
will tell you they discriminate against
men for these jobs and then we wonder
why there are more and more young men
that are unemployed well when you're
taking their jobs and giving them to the
women that's what you're going to see
guys and and it hurts the women that are
actually talented because do you know
what happens people just assume they're
there because of a quota the truth of
the matter is making money as a woman is
easier than ever and I think more men
should protest this stuff I think more
men I think that I think they should
make men's conferences if they're going
to make women's conferences but honestly
dividing it by the genders I think is
stupid just put the talented smart
people in a room all right Rena says why
am I seeing so many men at Grace Hopper
we can't have
anything well when you think about it
women are the ones that invaded male
spaces first we went into the workforce
we went into the bars we we wanted to do
Sports all of their stuff we invade and
then when they invade our stuff we cry
Autumn says it's that some men
are suddenly fake identifying was she
her pronouns to go to Grace Hopper
because they can't find jobs otherwise
at the same time be blatantly oppressing
people genuinely transitioning and and
embracing their gender identity any
woman that is stupid enough to believe
in gender identity I believe should be
banned from all the companies because
honestly if you can convince her that
there is gender identity God only knows
what you will convince her of the Grace
Hopper conference is specifically aimed
at wom intact and there are recruiters
there in order to push more hiring of
women in these fields it's been overrun
by men buying tickets I hate these
Freaks and I hate women that can't
compete either compete or get out we
don't need these special recruiters
giving us special jobs that we don't
deserve we don't need these special
privileges if you want to be in a man's
world then be in it and stop crying
about it I I encourage the men to buy
more tickets um and get rid of these
stupid conferences so let me know what
you guys think in the comments like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel and get yourself a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt today none of
this would have happened if women
didn't get the right to vote so like it
on your way out subscribe to the channel
and I'll talk to you next time